what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are going to watch
today the movie nope from jordan peel
john how are you i couldn't be more
excited are you ready to be super
intelligent today yes i am ready to be
intellectual to the utmost degree
filmmakers
talk deeper meanings look how smart we
are how observant i am
understand
nuance well you know what to do leave a
like that would really help us out in
the algorithm also be sure to subscribe
and click that notification bell got a
lot coming out over the next few weeks
also full length reaction watch alongs
where you sync up with your own copy of
nope over at our patreon page become a
super sexy reject today by checking out
everything we got to offer over there
cover a bunch of shows exclusively over
at our patreon reaction highlights and
watch alongs included a team of prepper
thank you for helping us edit down these
highlights let's swing into action
whoa
what happened at the ed sullivan show
oh man
i was like a ufo
[Music]
someone was moving in the background
there too
where are your sisters
what's that about
she's supposed to be here
yep
look at that frame yeah
lord i told you to fix today i'm walking
oh
someone screaming in the clouds
oh [ __ ] was he here oh no
[Music]
oh no
oh what an image to
oh
classic western what else what else
uh-huh
[Music]
yikes
[Music]
whoa it's like all that woman's
belongings just sprayed across the
valley this is o.j our horse trainer you
remember these guys from grosspoint yeah
hi
uh
your name is
o.j man i think my sister's gonna be
here in a minute
i'm so sorry about this
sorry bro
safety mean yeah
hello
now i know you guys know edward
morbridge the grandfather of motion
pictures who took the pictures that
created that clip but does anybody know
the name of the black jockey that rode
the horse nope
no
[Laughter]
that man was a bahamian jockey that went
by the name of aleister e haywood and he
is my
great-great-grandfather great there's
another great great that's why back at
the haywood ranch as the only
black-owned horse trainers in hollywood
we like to say since the moment pitchers
could move
we ask in the game
[Laughter]
uh and i'm emerald haywood i direct
write produce act i do a little singing
on the side
[Laughter]
i have a stack of business cards yeah um
hey hey hey hey man if she can't get
here
what are we doing here
hey i know your dad left an enormous
hole i know that but don't worry they'll
be ours
all right i'm sorry oh bummer
[Applause]
jordan peele does like his amusement
fair attraction parks and now you can
visit this at universal studios
who'd you bring me uh lucky it's my
second best horse you know
you lost focus i mean i did too but i
can't fire myself uh-huh
yeah my pops told me about this shoulder
the monkey went crazy or some [ __ ] you
know
i usually charge a fee for this
oh damn
oh
that's not good
damn
nope
that's the first exploding fist bump
holy crap he's got so much about this
it's one of the chimps that plays gory
just
hit his limit
and it was six minutes and 13 seconds of
havoc network tried to bury it but it
was a spectacle people are just obsessed
you're kidding me and now you can
capitalize off it
real geek show it's legendary
legendary [ __ ]
yeah
yeah i'm gonna have to go ahead look
that one up on youtube details you know
totally very productive meeting homeboy
is disturbed pops did something when he
made this place
he changed the industry
that's real
i can't just let that go
why is ghost in the arena oh
so much of this seems to be about the
unspoken historical impact that certain
people had
and the way in which it's like so
arbitrarily pushed around and yeah
erased and changed
now it's got some fun spooky [ __ ] come
on
i get it
good got my thinking done
[Laughter]
now make it rain metal again
[Music]
hey
you guys need walkie-talkies
for the last six months
how's that steven john yeah i think so
he's capitalizing on this
[Music]
i love her so much yeah right
the two of them together are polar
opposites but they're whoa
[Music]
what'd you see
it was big
i'll be big
it was fast
too fast
too quiet to be a plane
are you saying what i think you're
saying
terrorists
call the fbi
i'm saying there's plenty of videos for
flying [ __ ] online i saw one the other
day that wasn't on oprah i didn't say
oprah you said over you love oprah who
does it ain't nobody gonna get what we
gonna get what are we gonna get the shot
what's your
the shot the money shot undeniable
singular the
the oprah show
the outages affect the power and the
battery [ __ ] too like cell phones all
right cell phones
they don't just drop in power right i
mean maybe your wi-fi drops out whenever
your system dips
so
that's technology this is why fry shut
down yep [ __ ] like you i mean half
the staff was kind of like this
whoa look at me man
don't do that don't yell sorry man
i'm sorry if i was like a little shut
down this morning the [ __ ]
i know it's gonna sound [ __ ] cliche
all right but i thought that she was the
one
i got to go to the store and get stuff
don't worry about it you need anything
her name was uh rebecca diaz
[Laughter]
it's shitty footage of exact proof that
there's an alien civilization out there
in the universe
intergalactic travelers looking for
peace futuristic humans coming back in
time to stop us from destroying the
planet
or
they're [ __ ] world killers no not
that i can monitor the feed remotely
myself if you want
free of charge hell no
oh he's going to do it anyway
so what now
y'all know what you want to do
whatever you want to do well i got some
work that i do
it's a good one
really can't wait to talk about the
characterization between the two of them
yeah there's not enough time to get into
it in the middle of a reaction
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this was a lot more uh direct
yeah than i was expecting it to be yeah
even just with all the alienness about
it it's just like nope that's what we're
dealing with i only saw that one trailer
yeah like wow
that'd be a little bit more of like
would be like an hour and a half in
there yeah
what's going on yet
what the [ __ ]
oh damn so eerie nipple chills
nope
nope
[Music]
pretty much the reality of the situation
[Laughter]
cool what a great shot
oh no
don't oh with jupiter's claim
they're trying to prank haywood it's on
you stole that horse go get him go get
him em
whoa
camera b is down what
camera b
is down
like ancient [ __ ] aliens
[Music]
[Laughter]
this down more fun than i expected yeah
oh
here it goes
out to the sound design department man
yeah
oh
oh what
was that the horse i think so the metal
one maybe
yeah it took the bait it's gonna be
freaking dark brown in the sky
[Laughter]
um
it's in a cloud
listen a cloud
oh i got goose bumps like everywhere
dude
this is a really cool shot
wicked
no
oh that's really sad
the aliens are up there like you tricked
us
want the real thing
wow that's close to the ground love the
way they're
depicting this ship
of course max was in on it
maybe it was intentionally put there
yeah they don't have the technology to
put the cameras out
but we can influence the praying mantis
to block our path
i got a uh pretty damn superb
lemon tart in the oven i'm about to
serve this ten of my closest friends so
stop stop stop stop oh hold on one
second
what he's not here for that
no
according to
american cinema magazine you make the
cinematically impossible possible
well
we're looking for the impossible shot
that's impossible
the stream you're chasing
the one where you end up at the top of
the mountain
all eyes on you
it's the dream you never wake up from
[Laughter]
i don't like them
what a strange
cinematographer
yep doesn't move exactly
oh eerie are you guys telling me
that there's an alien spaceship
that [ __ ] cloud right there
it doesn't move like a ship
what if it's not a ship
what does it mean
yeah what
we going back and of course i set it to
icelandic time because we share a love
of the aurora borealis gordy you have no
idea how to tell time great gift dad i
need to think things through
surprise wow now that is a gift
oh sorry fine that's right from there
wait a minute what happened to we both
that's very real oh
damn
[Applause]
[Music]
this movie makes me scared to work with
animals on set
same time they had to use animals
it all had to work to make this
nightmare a reality
yeah i feel you
what was your objective man
you're not the wrangler
oh he liked him
world's first exploding fist bump
everyone thought that was a horse's hand
in the tree
[Laughter]
are they gonna be human horse hybrids
oh my god damn it no
i mean i know gordy wasn't the best but
i want to thank you guys for coming out
here
but first clouds are moving i also want
to give a special thanks to
an old co-star of mine
and my first crush
mary jo elliott everyone
oh she survived dang oh
oh wow
i could barely see my hand in front of
my face for the fog
but i swear
on my wife
and children's lives
i see
a flying saucer oh damn that's why he's
here
old trigger took off straight into the
gulch
well
it's like he was going home
[Music]
oh my god is he sacrificing the horses
that's what it looks like from here
ah they're coming out to play today it's
not your cue
wow
uh uh stay in your seats
this is new uh they're early
which is huh
amen
cool
that was awesome
[Music]
reverse birth canal
i want a refund
i am leaving a one star review on yelp
[Music]
oh man you were just [ __ ] if you just
brought your damn camera okay
and now you get your horse back come on
man put two and two together
oh no
oh you hear them
that is eerie
from underneath it kind of looks like a
big cowboy hat
um fan theory this is when oj died
and the rest is his death hallucination
this is serotonin
[Music]
come on man you're one of the smart ones
[ __ ]
it ain't the man
it's alive
it's an animal
it's territorial
really i guess that thing could be a
mouth
what does gordie have to do with it
oh my god jesus
oh god i guess it is just an animal
digestion complete
[Music]
[Music]
gross
we're
gnarly
i love it
that's pretty cool
yes what an image that is awesome
oh my god
you know people told me this was great
on imax and now i i'm starting to see
why
why
is the one that got away
[Laughter]
that thing is spiteful it knows
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow
i love it
you're in its world now
playing chicken i actually wonder if
there's like fans there's a face of what
i said
it does look like some weird like
hellish pregatory landscape we're in
silent hill now
[Music]
he's trying to it yeah or
yeah give them a signal
ish
she won't move you oh yes
oh hey horsey hey don't don't look at an
eyes please don't look at the alien
huh
don't look up that's i bet that's what
he wanted to call it
[Laughter]
[Music]
what about lucky
[Music]
i wear my sunglasses tonight
gotta feed her
they lucky out
oh come on man [ __ ] to do
always
took a second
cloud he moved to god damage he noticed
how about we
send old jean jackets and fresh horses
and golden hour and see what happens
the most beautiful ufo footage
set them free we're not doing that
okay
characters remain likable
save the horse moment later myself
no electricity
did not tell you this [ __ ] was
gonna come up here with a nine
camera
let's go boy
[Laughter]
he's mad
he's got a lot of spirit but anything
with a spirit can get broke
so you'll break it
i get the shot
it's probably the first time i guys
smiled in 10 years what we're doing is
important right
like
what we document
it's um
it's gonna do some good
get your girl back he was
ironic they'd use monopoly pieces i like
that one of jordan peele's main motifs
is like taking in a
a popular innocuous song and making it
horrifying
it's kind of the scorpion king going on
go from rage against the machine right
into scorpion king
[Music]
do you think the news stations are
trying to find them yeah
wacky waving inflatable arm flailing
tube man
and um
man down what where
let's dance
god this guy must really have money if
his one for me is on imax film
this [ __ ]
man in black on a white motorcycle oh he
wants to get a glimpse too
let him be the bait
yeah
yep
[Music]
you see that cloud
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
who are you
what is that voice oh my god
what did happen with juke park and all
those people he was basically your
neighbor right so what they vanished you
don't believe the flood narrative do you
guys
it's tmz
let tmz be the bait yeah
you're lost nobody
[Applause]
what happens when an electric bike going
60 miles per hour gets an anti-electric
feel going in the opposite direction
get them
[Music]
[Laughter]
so much more of a sense of humor i
expected it yeah
it's his funniest horror movie
i told him not to go
oh jay let him die where's my camera
hey i need my camera do you see it
angel
angel come on we gotta reload
i mean i would have just waited till
[ __ ] started going out yeah can't just
afford to roll all day on that [ __ ]
please
[Music]
christ
scorpion king
make a name for yourself
what is
that i'm bad man
oh my god
come on
angel i swear to god as you better
[Music]
[Music]
love the old-timey score too
what's up everyone
don't look up man don't look up you know
the rules
don't look at its mouth eye
how you get here screaming
somebody give me my camera
i need the footage
[Applause]
oh no
oh no
holy [ __ ] i think it's taking the
dancers are you getting this
i sure friggin hope so with that film
load
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's become the cowboy
make an agreement
come on
[Music]
whoa
the texture
[Music]
[Music]
got it it's over no it's not no no it's
not over it's gonna be all right angel
we don't deserve the impossible
what
hey host
[Music]
just for the best shot possible
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
and spit the camera out and have a found
footage movie
[Music]
stop looking dude
oh yay yes good
oh is that his film room yeah so we got
it the real popped out piece of the
camera
oh [ __ ]
what's it doing
[Music]
no
the records
oh
[Music]
is he in there oh thank god
holy god
it's like a
intergalactic jellyfish
[Music]
[Music]
oh
man oh jay
come on work together guys
[Music]
man that's really heartbreaking
[Music]
oh
no
[Music]
[Music]
it's out of range
[Music]
jeez
damn what a great shot
yikes
[Music]
[Laughter]
i haven't seen akira but he did the
akira slide
good
catch r.i.p jordan peels
[Music]
akira is this part of the plan
i guess
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
smart
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
get the perfect shot
the impossible shot
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna take you over
[Music]
[Music]
nice
p.o.v
[Music]
and it was a golden hour
oh wow
it's gotta hurt it oh yeah
oh there we go there we go
yup
yep
damn
why didn't you put grenades inside of
should
that
planned this out better you could rig
something explosive up on a farm
hide the photos
yeah hide the photos hide the photos
come on
[Music]
[Music]
yes
my
man and it's like it's pointing at it
perfect shot
doesn't get any better than that justice
for gordy justice
all right got my jacket on
that was a
experience right there what an
experience so much to talk about
so much to go into
so much
from the filmmaking to the characters
to the
many
different
themes you can interpret here there's
like so many different ways to interpret
um
you know from the uh
obvious stuff about capitalism and
exploitation of real life things
obsession with fame greed but then also
like redemption
uh there's i love the arc of them
i just love i love the book end of this
of how
this haywood family has just been
disregarded they were they were so
integral to the development of hollywood
and so it means a like it makes so much
sense why it's so important to them to
get this shot and i even love that
allegory i don't know allegory but like
uh a supplement
of of doing a western instead of
shooting a camera shooting a gun you're
shooting a camera and you're getting
your final shot
off at the end yeah yeah the final shot
is with the lens instead of going on it
so that's so cool because it's a western
showdown at the end it's a western
finale yeah and and but uh instead of a
gun we're shooting you're you're
shooting with a lens you know and i
think that's really neat but also like
the the gratification the importance of
how
they should have had this staple and be
cemented in hollywood and be recognized
their family history and lineage and now
they got the shot they got the proof
they got the evidence they got it all
and now they can have the legacy they
deserve so i think it's just such a neat
ending uh when you bookend it with that
but uh
yeah anyway john want you to actually
really kick it off why don't you really
kick it off
no i mean i i absolutely agree with
everything no
no
nope nope sorry that's what i should
have said i agree with everything you
just said i mean i was really dazzled by
this and i feel like this is a
deceptively straightforward movie i
think it's perhaps one of
you know the three jordan peel films
we've seen thus far this is perhaps the
one that to me communicates the biggest
sort of convergence of themes that are
shared and i know in the past he's said
you know like the humans are always the
monsters in my movies but i feel like
this kind of
breaks from that in a very interesting
way and yeah there's a lot you can glean
about
uh i don't know like like
i feel like
with the fact that they are animal
trainers and you meet them on set in
this moment where everyone's like trying
to have a safety meeting but clearly
nobody is really that concerned for
safety and they just kind of want
everything to go on their schedule or
whatever and then you look at the stuff
with gordy and i feel like there are
certain comments being made about just
like the the assumption that we have
control over all of this and and that
everything does kind of run at our women
whimsy
and uh and the ways in which you know we
orchestrate these fantasies and yeah we
re we erase real life history even
though the evidence is actually there
and we push those details around and we
recontextualize them and
and yeah like there's
it's yeah it feels like a deceptively
straightforward film because like the
the main plot is pretty straightforward
but yeah it's like okay why are we
choosing to focus on this particular
array of characters who work in and
around the film industry but all of our
yeah protagonists or our main ensemble
are people who
you know are pieces of that machine but
they're not the famous ones they're not
the ones at the top of that food chain
and it's interesting to see how you know
you got jup
who has clearly taken you know aspects
of his childhood experience as an
entertainer and is
re-working and repurposing them for you
know his current living
uh as like a sideshow attraction and
probably banking on the idea that people
know that gordy incident and i love that
especially with him they give him these
little moments of reverie
and they'll give you maybe one flash of
like the traumatic event he's actually
experiencing as he is actively
participating in the spin
so i don't know there's so many places
to start i feel like but i mean i guess
the heart and soul of this is uh uh
daniel kaluya and kiki palmer like at
the at the heart of it like i love their
their dynamic and the way in which they
are two completely different characters
and without doing too much deep diving
into here's their backstory in their
past here's a flashback both of them is
kids and we're gonna see like they they
really communicated how and why the
characters exist the way they do just
through the immediate performance i felt
like
yeah with the oj character he's someone
who
there's always this sense because
there's a sheep his dad
keith david uh exudes such a
uh a charisma and confidence
that a and a determination and focus
that even um
emerald has you know
and he doesn't have that and he's even
shunned on set at the beginning of this
film
you know like he doesn't have the energy
and he's not even looked at as being all
that great he's maybe not the best
businessman either they don't they're
not deep diving into it but clearly
he's not looked upon as being good
enough
and then by the end of the film with him
to arc into this of like oh he
the fact that because you got these two
like different characters here with
brother and sister
which by the way i love that jordan
peels like explore different
relationships like how
get out is uh boyfriend and girlfriend
and then us as a family and then this is
brother and sister i think it's really
cool that he's like established these
very specific dynamics to dive into
but like with emerald you you get the
sense that you know she probably grew up
on this farm and then wanted to get away
and have a little bit more of a city
life and and really enjoy herself and
get into entertainment in some form you
know like if she's even promoting that
for herself and like this isn't what i
really want to do whereas like oj didn't
seem to really pursue any other avenues
and kind of just got pushed into this
and he's stuck here but this is act and
then by the end of the movie you're
seeing like by the finale that
everything that's sort of weighed down
on him and everything he's had to endure
he this is his strength and he gets to
utilize that and it also creates this
great sense of pride with their family
by the end of it you know like where
emerald is someone who's kind of been
running away and sort of rejecting this
and is that helping out right now yada
yada i'm going to grab my stuff and get
out of here but then by the end when
they take down that alien and she's like
don't [ __ ] with the hayward family like
i'm like oh this is so cool like it is a
story about the it is at the end of the
day a story about the brother and sister
more more than anything else
you know and also um
i love the supporting cast a lot too the
guy plays angel
i thought he was great he has that
at the beginning i was like yeah you're
kind of frustrating but he's just so
funny in his cynicism and then
eventually you're like i know he's a
good guy he's a cool guy and michael
wincott too has such a
such a great presence with a gruff voice
of his
and
he's someone i've grown up watching a
lot because he's been around for decades
and never quite got the level of fame i
think he deserved because he does carry
such weight with him whenever he's on
screen and whenever he's on screen
anything it's like a shitty movie he
tends to be someone who steals the show
yeah he he is a high caliber actor and i
i loved it i think there's a lot of
commentary to be made all around but
like just sticking to the filmmaking
aspect side of it i think it's really
cool how this movie does at first just
seemed like just a straightforward
ufo movie i'm like okay it's kind of got
that science feel this is what it was
picking up on like oh you're not really
gonna see the aliens but it's an alien
invasion thing okay it's abduction all
right it makes sense yeah yeah yeah
but then to actually turn it from a
sci-fi move i mean it's still sci-fi the
genre that comes next but to turn it
from an alien sci-fi movie into a
monster movie
was even cooler to me like oh what a
flip what a what a turn
and
it does
kind of make you think of films like
uh
not so much i guess to a certain way of
jurassic park monitor monetary gain with
this larger-than-life creature yeah like
like like king kong actually uh i think
is a is a good thing to pull from like
with king kong with like a filmmaking
crew we got to capture them you know
yeah and so i think there's a lot of
these cool riffs of different
different genres just spliced into here
from
sci-fi monster movie western
uh
i don't know if the right term would be
buddy comedy but in some ways it is it's
funny it's funnier than i expected it to
be like it's a lot funnier than i
thought it would be yeah and there's a
lot that's played off of that dynamic
and there's a lot of humor you wouldn't
have expected that comes out of
especially the the oj and emerald
relationship and other characters like
angel and whatnot like there's there's a
real quirkiness of character overall but
i'd say buddy is a is a fair
assessment i like stephen young's
performance a lot i thought the gordy
thing was going to like
like strong it seems like it's more of a
metaphorical thing i'm not even sure how
to really
pick up on it full fully like you were
touching on some things i was like oh
okay okay that sounds better than what i
i was maybe picking up on
well i think you have to respect nature
in a way like there's a food chaininess
about all this to me because i mean i
feel like with gordy there's some
element of
the power's not out but that shoe
standing straight up just reads as some
kind of weird alien influence on the
situation but more so than that and as
he's telling the story you don't even
know if that thing about the jungle is
true but you can see it reflected in the
scene when you know oj is setting up
with the horse and trying to do the
safety meeting it's like these people
are expecting that yeah this this animal
is just going to be our prop and do what
we needed to do and everything's gonna
be fine
and yet this is still a part of nature
that yeah you need to make that
agreement back and forth with and just
the way that we might have plucked this
creature out of obscurity to dance for
our pleasure now this creature has moved
in and is you know eating up and
swallowing people and you know feeding
like a predator would well i think also
there is a a lot
that which i find i would really be
curious is the one part of this whole
movie that i'd be curious about the
onset treatment was for was how they did
because i mean obviously gordy was cgi
yeah um but then you know he got a bunch
of horses in here and there's been
controversy over the years of use of
animals in films i know a lot of animal
lovers who
hate the use of any animals in films
like it's just something that they don't
feel like animals
should be doing just generally speaking
and a lot of times you know if it's
something that easy to be like whatever
like it's easy to roll your eyes and
gawk at what they're saying
but every once in a while even for
myself i'll hear things and i'll be like
that's actually not a bad point you know
bad things happen yeah and then even
with like having a chimp on set you know
like that could be a disastrous
situation
because this is not their environment or
the one they should the environment they
should be inhabiting you know what i
mean yeah and no matter how much there's
an animal trainer it's not the life
a chimp
wants or needs or deserves yeah so there
is a strange like type of but i'm
thinking more of how to how does it tie
into the whole thing i think it just
mainly serves the
part of the theme at least what i was
getting from it was with
the
again the gate the capitalism side of
this movie of trying to find that
monetary gain again because like
all stephen young this juke character
has such a traumatic incident but yet
tries to profit off of it now and tries
to exploit it and now he's got another
opportunity with this alien thing that
he's discovered and now how can i profit
off like this
it's like a weird psychological
recreation but also yes circa that yeah
gotta get that picture gotta gotta use
this to my advantage yeah it's like an
alien sighting is is by and large it
would seem a traumatic incident for
people but there is that drive to be
like no we gotta capture it though we
gotta be the ones because some of the
commentary is way more overt
it's weird because get out had that like
perfect balance
of commentary right for at least a lot
of people it's all open to
interpretation and then us kind of went
sewed into the into the neck
of it
some people were like what
i don't i don't understand and then here
some they sometimes get even more
direct than i expected it to be you know
when you flat out just have a oh he's
from teen like she just picks up he's
from tmz yeah you know and
we all know everything about the
exploitative qualities of what a tmz
person is like yeah yeah yeah and now
people are taking interest in their
little operation just because they have
some kind of exploitable scenario on
their hands yeah and yeah i feel like
this movie has
definitely is compared to
get out in us at least you know here in
this moment i feel like where those
movies have a bit more of a straight or
at least a more uh singular or unified
kind of subtext they're they're getting
out i feel like this movie does have
more the same way like a film set has
many converging departments and many
converging art forms and themes at work
i feel like that's happening in this
movie too it's like there's a lot that
you could say about
documentation and surveillance and you
know again the order of nature and like
you were talking about with like
capitalism and exploiting trauma and
exploiting natural occurrences and
things like that like i feel like this
is a movie that
for being as straightforward as it is i
appreciate that it balanced that without
losing or it balanced it with that
quality of you have this gorty sequence
which i feel like for a lot of viewers
could read as sort of like a random
interlude or something that's a bit more
obtuse in the overall picture but i feel
like you know you have a bunch of people
interacting with this environment that
are all coming from different
backgrounds different traumas elements
of their history are in the forefront or
have been covered up in different ways
and so yeah i think this is a movie more
so than the previous two that you can
draw a lot of different perspectives out
of
and i think that's a really cool way to
go about it too i don't think you
necessarily have to be like no the movie
is about this under the surface it could
be an array of things because that's i
feel like that's more akin to to life
even yeah it's funny because this movie
to me at least upon first viewing seems
like it's more overt than his other
films and yet some stuff is still a
little bit more unclear than his other
films yeah yeah depending on what
subject matter you're talking about
because it does start with gordy
and
and and uh from it starts from the pov
as a reveal it's from the pov of jupe
yeah and they don't reveal that's jupe's
pov until later on in the film
and you know they have that thing with
the shoe
that's standing up and he's kind of
distracted by it and
he's not looking at the animal like he's
looking at the shoe right
and it seemed like that's just a big
like foreshadowing symbolism shot that
you have the chimp
the ufo the animal
he's not looking at the animal he's
looking at the bad miracle essentially
yeah you know and that's that's where
his direction is pointed at his because
i don't know what the hell it up that uh
that's the only thing i can at least
gather from what the hell the standing
shoe would mean yeah in a situation like
that yeah it's like this is not a good
thing but it's kind of a
i don't know if i call it a miracle but
it is
a bit odd yeah well yeah it's like a
freak natural occurrence and you can you
could argue that maybe even though again
it's not hailed by uh electrical cut out
like maybe it is that like the the chimp
just goes nuts for that period of time
when that entity is present and then
yeah eventually reverts and two i mean i
thought there was an interesting
parallel there too because like you know
in different ways obviously the kid much
more sentient much more aware of this
but you're both kind of being plucked
into a dog and pony show yeah that you
don't both fully understand and so like
i thought there was an interesting that
fist bump moment is an interesting
little bit of unity because it's like we
are sort of the two people here who are
like the most sort of innocent and being
just swept up in this orchestration of
you know things everybody thinks they
can control
and are just okay and of course i don't
know how this was not mentioned the
surveillance theme
to it all yeah like you're literally
being surveilled they bring up
surveillance everything's captured like
there's so much about use of capturing
stuff on camera and yeah you know like
there's there's so much happening in
this one film and i think
it doesn't feel messy to me like i don't
know i i still i still even after first
viewing you know i haven't really had as
much time for it nowhere near because
i'm just talking about right now um for
it to like sink in with me uh fully
it does sort of feel like this would be
my third out of the jordan peel films
but that's a still
not that doesn't mean i don't love this
film though like i really i thought it
was i think it's a great film i i would
just rank it third for me out of the
three that he's uh directed so far
because i've the only thing i've really
heard about this movie
um
the only thing i've really heard is is
pot
kind of that rhetoric is that i hear
it's a little bit more fun
and
that uh
it's maybe not his best one that's what
i've heard
and
i didn't know what to get going in
because i've only saw the i didn't know
the specifics of why people were saying
that i had only seen the first trailer i
heard there was another trailer that was
more revealing so we didn't even cover
on this channel i never watched it on my
own time never played in the theaters
either whenever i went
so i was expecting to at least still be
like that first trailer which this movie
does not really have that vibe for most
of the movie right because that for sure
it was like brilliant that's an
excellent trailer well they barely show
you any they don't show you anything
alien you're just left to go this feels
kind of like an alien yeah yeah and it
feels like they're doing you know
experimentation film and people are
reading into all kinds of things i love
how every theory was wrong on this movie
yes like every theory is wrong yeah yeah
people were like the the messed up face
girl
the the actress who survived yeah oh she
a horse human hybrid
oh my god that yeah there was all that
and the yeah that the fist is like some
kind of hybrid horse baby or something
like that instead of a monkey yeah and
also uh okay it's with black people it's
short appeal so are they taking black
people and turning them into horses
this is slave labor allegory what is
sorry to bother you too
yeah or is it are they abducting the
culture and appropriating it
why are they slicing them with horses
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's why my mind
was even going is gordy a former human
is is this horse a human
yeah totally totally i mean it's it is
that brain t see the funny thing is for
me this is the one of his movies
just on first impression i was like this
is the one i would probably put on the
most just because this is the movie i
want to hang out with the most like i
really love the atmosphere and the aura
of being in this movie and all the
different places and i love that you
spend so much time of it in this in agua
dulce and like away from
the you know uh you know hubbub and the
the ridiculousness almost of the film
set and there is a quality too that's
like not in your face like this is a
movie about people who work on movies
and like that's a pretty well-worn
like i would call that probably like a
sub-genre in here somewhere because
everybody even
even the guy who's not fully like a
movie-making character in angel is still
like you know knows tech and cameras and
is all about kind of documenting these
things
and uh and yeah it's like it doesn't
have that like indulgent celebratory
aspect that those movies have but it
does have that flavor too like
everybody's an entertainer and it struck
me i was like is this significant that
yeah the the girl
who the other survivor of the gordy set
massacre
she comes and you know she's got the
veil on it's such a striking image and
then ostensibly she just swallowed up
you know so i'm like is that unfinished
business from the pat like like there
are those things that i leave a movie
like this excited to ponder and excited
to discuss with people because i'm like
that seems really pointed and really
deliberate except i'm not sure what
that's about i mean she's brought there
and for the rest of her life she's known
as a survivor of that incident and then
she's brought there to be thanked by the
other guy the guy who survived and got
away clean up and said who is that and
who doesn't have to wear a t-shirt of
himself with his old face on it yeah
like
no no she's being exploited yeah or this
is the only thing she can really do yeah
it's like the lines between exploitation
and entertainment and the life that art
imitates yeah i think it's so i i think
is very i think the one thing with
jordan peele is that he's
is very intentional filmmaker and it's
also like a sci-fi just b movie in a lot
of ways too yeah and like a really high
budget
i don't actually i don't this is one
house no
this is actually just a universal joint
i think so yeah because i don't think he
needs he's got his own blumhouse in
monkey's paw now so yeah cause this
movie is uh
definitely looked the most more
expensive one of his films yeah and i
mean there's a whole shot where it's
just in the sky one a lot of their like
i admired the contrast of you have like
some really beautiful night you know low
light photography sequences but you have
a lot in broad daylight with clouds and
and you know
using
the things that can obscure your vision
in broad daylight for that and so like
you know for a lot of this you needed to
have a good amount of effects a for the
chimp and that's even harder than an
alien ship i think because you know
that's more there's a better chance to
get to the uncanny valley because
obviously most people know what chimps
look like but
but i love the
the twist on the alien ship not being a
ship it's the creature itself yeah and
the way in which the creature evolves
and you get these little glimp like you
start the movie out basically in its
mouth
and then uh you know you go from there
to seeing how it becomes this big
billowing like it's almost beautiful by
the end but also very sort of strange
and foreign looking
and uh yeah that could not have been
cheap
no no no not at all yeah that was a cool
movie i thought it was really cool yeah
i i had a i had a lot of fun with it and
i think everything from a technical
standpoint is excellent especially the
way he handled
i mean obviously the whole thing with
the
i mean i think the twist that it's
actually i didn't see that coming at all
that that the the it's not a ufo
because it's completely designed to look
like you ate
yeah um so i didn't see that twist
coming at all that's an actual creature
i wasn't even exactly sure what he what
um oj was getting at yeah yeah when he
when he said like maybe it's not a ship
like what are you talking about i had no
idea what he was saying
um
it's an aircraft of some kind
yeah so when um so when that reveal did
happen i think that that it was a
brilliant because it makes it a lot
scarier
at that point and it it puts everything
in a different perspective yeah like
when they are
when they are
in the earlier parts of the movie when
when you could hear the screaming voices
inside of
the creature and you're like okay it
must be like alien experiments going on
and it kind of gives you hope that maybe
there's a way to get out of it too yeah
you know and then you're like oh no
they're just being devoured yeah
that's awesome it's just spitting out
everything it can't digest
and the way he handled perspective on
not only the exteriors of the skies and
such which by the way i love because a
lot of the times it would become these
semi one takes that felt a little bit
like a video game you know like in in
video games where it's
it's not
first person pov but it's like close to
the characters still see the exterior
yeah like it's right behind you and
everybody's like the person next to you
yeah exactly and and i love the way
those shots were handled and um but even
some of the inside shots like like when
the people are just being sucked up and
like that is and now then when it gets
like really scuzzy and internal and
you're like what the [ __ ]
is this lizard yeah you're like this
doesn't look like some big like he's
clueing you in that this is a creature
yeah this isn't [ __ ] there's not gonna
be a big control center with computers
and stuff yeah it's just gonna be more
and more like organ strange for an
organic material
yeah and then how it resides in the sky
um i thought that was great i think just
a straight thought but i feel like
part of this is is too about like the
ways in which everybody in their own
different ways like engaged with
storytelling and recording surveillance
etc because you have your your two
protagonists who are like in the sort of
like work a day world of fantasy
orchestration like they have he's
talking about i got mal's defeat i gotta
get up in the morning i gotta prep the
horses i gotta walk him around you know
like that's that's the day-to-day grunt
work and then you have somebody like jup
who is you know more of the celebrity
traumatic story aside celebrity
character and then you have the
cinematographer you have antlers
who literally is there to like die for
the art who's just like you know you you
will never get that perfect shot so i'm
going to die
getting the impossible shot like it's
everybody's dedication to the art in a
way and it almost seems like it comes
out on this balance of like you know uh
uh oj and m are gonna be
certainly better off than they were
before because they have like now
clinched their place in cinema history
but also you know like they're they're
on like the most level ground out of
everybody because they do have to just
live on the ground with the normal
people you know
i do think the
see i think i get why people would judge
this movie a more
like
heart be harsher
on this movie
as compared to his other films
because it's jordan peele
if this was some
random filmmaker like up and coming guy
and they made this people be like this
is brilliant who is this i know this was
a debut people would lose their minds
but it's it's just the fact that he
whatever he makes it's going to be
compared to his other movies yeah that's
just the position he's in right now but
even us was divisive upon first arrival
i feel like and i feel like some people
had a stronger negative reaction to us
which in some ways i guess is worse you
never want like a meh reaction but
yeah i mean i to me he's clinched that
debut three like you always point out
like you gotta have three great films to
like solidify your yeah they're
different well i think us while getting
that negative reaction i think a lot of
people couldn't wrap their heads around
the concept even i had to kind of
like look into it a little bit more be
like what the there's some stuff i just
don't get yeah i i don't understand yeah
um
and so and i think that detracts i
remember even being at the theater and
some strangers just talking to us i had
no idea who we were like real rejects it
wasn't even that and he hated it
some black dude who came up to us or
just like hated the movie yeah yeah
and
and every time we were like i don't know
i kind of liked it i was like nah man
let me tell you a little bit more about
why i didn't like it yeah and that had a
lot to do with how he like he couldn't
understand what the reveal was people
get upset about
that that thing of like a very fine line
how you handle a review yeah and how you
handle ambiguity and you're not there's
a certain percentage of people you're
not gonna please that way but it is
interesting to find the line where
people go okay i'm excited to ponder
this versus oh what a cop-out you didn't
even bother to you know fill us in on
what you're trying to do you know
well i to me it's like the
uh not that i want to make this a
comparison video to those other films
the
the i thought the first like hour and a
half of us is more thrilling than this
movie like i was i was so i was like on
the edge of my seat with that first hour
and a half and i i really love the mood
of that like this is fun
this is really fun and engaging and
there are some suspenseful exciting i
got goosebumps quite a few times when
watching this and yeah you know i can't
say a lot of movies really do that for
me you know i usually just get like
nipple chills but goosebumps all over my
body and where i'm like it's all over
it's full of chill yeah that that was um
that was provocative to me i [ __ ]
loved it yeah absolutely so i really i
thought this was a really great film and
i think
another a lot of people are also kind of
writing this off as it's not it doesn't
have any deeper meaning or anything like
that and i'm like i don't know about
that i mean i i think
i think that there's a lot of things
that are not like fully laid out for a
reason because you kind of have to
interpret it and i don't know what uh
i've yet to watch a think piece or
anything explained or a breakdown of it
because they're all filled with spoilers
so i i imagine there are more
intellectual people than
myself out there who have really
ridden some great [ __ ] yeah to explain
that taking all the time to consider and
yeah and and hammer down that argument
yeah this is a brainstorm discussion
here and i i i think that there is some
wonderful nuance to it
i guess the thing that
sometimes the humor is very rare
i think the tmz thing kind of pushed it
a little too far with the comedy for me
if i had like a detail to pick apart
like a little too much
it is the most straight parody it's it's
the most straightforward and it's it's
weird because it's one of those times
where parts of the subtext do start to
breach over into like the literal text
where i'm like okay i can
i can tell like any time tmz shows up i
feel like it becomes this low-hanging
fruit of like and now we're gonna do
toxic surveillance culture commentary
because this guy only cares about his
camera and is completely oblivious to
the rest of the situation and is like a
dick about it too
so yeah like it's like his teeth then
again yes the problem is like that's not
wrong but but also
but also you would hope that yeah in an
environment like this and it's not the
point but yeah you could hope that the
human might shine through yeah because
that's what the rest of the movie is
doing and you see a character like angel
who i didn't expect because i haven't
seen brandon perea much before so i was
like okay this is gonna be a one-off bit
for people who know fry's electronics
and that character is not gonna come
back and then this character who
presents as an [ __ ] who's disengaged
then becomes endearing over time and in
the same movie i would have yeah
expected a little sprinkling of humanity
on the tmz guy
or something because also too he shows
up with this like reflective helmet and
i was like you seem like someone who
might know [ __ ] about what's actually
going on but no it's it's just uh it's
just harvey levin this would have some
great stunt work in here too
totally like i love this shot when uh uh
emerald is uh is uh
when it looks like she's about to be
taken and she's just like thrown into
the other side yeah that was that whole
sequence i thought the way the handling
perspective on that did feel
at times like when you're watching of a
video game character what is that pov
style called
is it a
heads-up display is that what it's
called i think so
i don't
i don't know i've never bothered or i
mean you could just call it
kind of like the batman or spider-man
games but not a
not literally first person but it's oh
my god do i not know any video game
names anymore
you got it you gotta [ __ ] dude
not doom pov but uh yeah yeah
but uh yeah it's still like a first
person perspective because i think this
the smart thing is they do so much
both
camera motion but also they just put the
camera in places a human would be so
you're watching that all happen from eye
level you know and that i think lends
this quality of like it feels like
you're just there watching this take
place
and the way they move the camera isn't
like super shaky and crazy it's it's
usually with the fluidity that you know
you could whip your neck around
so yeah like there is
a bit of that video game heads-up
display kind of vibe there and i think
it's chosen really well and it enhances
really well and and two i mean like
you've got a lot of great horse
based stunts which i feel like they
recreate that you know profile galloping
shot at one point and like you know they
do uh with daniel kaluya like he's
riding and stuff and like he even came
off natural and and you know having
having grown up with people who rode
horses oftentimes i can you know at
least know enough to see when i'm like
oh this actor hasn't really written
before
or you know isn't really kind of in uh
unison with the horse but even those
things like felt really natural and like
the
the way they embody the whole just
life on the ranch i really bought you
know i think daniel kaluuya is an easy
performance to overlook no he does not
have a
hypnotized and oh my god look at him cry
brilliant acting single tears that's
really brilliant to get out he is he's
brilliant um i think he's great here i i
think he's absolutely excellent i love
how uh subtle and internal his whole
performance is
and
so much of him just feels it feels
really human
in a situation that is so science
fiction
yeah and he's really great at not yeah
like playing this
laconic character doesn't talk much and
who also like isn't the most expressive
but still exudes so much light it's like
in that scene where the kids are
pranking him in the barn he's not like
freaking out trembling his face is
mostly still but you can still feel
what's going on underneath and i think
yeah he's he is terrific and i felt this
since
black mirror and get out especially is
he's great at throwing things away but
in a meaningful way yeah you know well i
think he he has a very specific choices
in this movie too with his body language
like kind of hunched over it looks like
he gained a little bit of weight for
this role
too and then uh like that
his his difficulty making eye contact
yeah i think is another great choice for
this kind of character as well and then
it contrasts so well with kiki palmer
who is like the total opposite but they
do feel like brother and sister yeah
they they have such great chemistry
together even though their energies are
wildly different
and i like moments that don't as much as
sometimes it becomes very meta and you
become very aware you're watching a
movie and that might be one of the
detracting qualities for me is that
i wasn't ever fully immersed in this
movie
i would i was pretty much aware i was
watching a film the whole time
and um but i still love i still love
that though because i think that's the
the it's so aware because especially
when you're doing a movie about making
movies and filming all this stuff i'm
gonna be naturally more aware than the
way they talk about like this like the
cinematographer character antlers like
his character in particular there's just
more things to make me aware of what i'm
watching
like when you're going to fry's
electronics and you're dealing with this
tech guy and i'm like i know so many
guys like this dude
i have been in this exact situation at
that exact store yeah yeah but then like
the the cinematographer personality
seems to be a uh like uh it doesn't
broach into the
you know the tmz guy it's not caricature
but it is like a cheek
because yeah of course the
cinematographer of everyone on set would
be this guy yeah with this motivation
who is willing to come out for the
project for the arch for the perfect
shot he will die for like yeah
yeah there are things like that
um because there are scenes where i'm
definitely fully immersed in other times
where i would just be more observant
um what was the point beforehand
um movies about making movies
and them kind of breaking the meta
fourth wall that way or not being fully
immersed um those are all the points i
was already making the point before that
i'm trying to walk backwards one step at
a time
run backwards uh we were talking about
daniel kaluuya and his uh lost
understated performance
kiki palmer and him
doesn't matter
gordy
you know too i think the
another thing too is that animals often
don't get
as much as there's uh uh
you know and we've heard story i feel
like most of us by this point i've heard
some of the horror stories that happened
on sets with animals there's a famous
one that was going around with the dogs
in that christian movie it was a
christian movie
yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't remember
something recently though yeah was it
was it a dog's purpose
i think or was it the other one that
came out around the same time that had a
similar title i don't know if it was a
dog's way home or something like that
but one of those yeah had like egregious
onset animal well it's easy to do that
yeah it's easy it's easy to mistreat
animals but one thing i loved was how
they would show like they would cut to
the
the characters they treated the horses
like actual characters yeah and each one
of them has a moment to kind of advance
the the mystery by responding directly
to what's going on yeah yeah and there
there's a significance to the animals so
yeah yeah this was uh a very it was i i
guess out of the the three this is his
most self-aware movie sure yeah i would
say so and so that made me more of a
self-aware viewer yeah yeah because i
bet i bet some of his experience is not
that he has the same experiences as
these characters but i bet some of his
experiences
in the film industry at large but
especially as a director have probably
helped influence what this became
because not even like a director
character no no i mean you know you have
you have oz perkins and you have like
that one other guy who's like doing the
main communications at the front but
it's not even quite clear what their
roles are on set and yeah it's like of
of everybody on set the only person who
really like makes an impression and
stands out is the does the dp
but he's so fun he is i love that
character he's
he's
oh like has so like just too much
gravity toss
to the point
that you're like it's funny and it's
working though yeah yeah this could have
easily just been a parody you know yeah
of that only people who like film would
get totally of the obsessed cinnamon a
lot of people don't know what a
cinematographer is
like but this does shine a light on like
what a cinematographer actually does you
know yeah and again they are inclined i
would i would guess that stereotype they
would be inclined to be the most sort of
like high-minded you know i'm the
observer of the set i am the most
bird's-eye view on all these
circumstances it is through my eye this
is seen like you could totally see how
they would be usually they make that
character the director yeah yeah
absolutely whereas no i mean the
cinematographer yeah you're the one who
has to translate the director's neurosis
into an image all right guys please tell
us down below your thoughts of what you
interpret nope to be about subscribe
click that bell leave a like last but
not least i'll send this with a patron
of the day shout out
michael linden
mikhail yes wanted to shout you out
because this movie
stars black people
and you were the whitest person we know
you are you would be because you take
over the spotlight now that's what you
do
yeah
this video has been all about you this
whole time my dude this is your time to
shine you are the guy who captured the
man riding the horse you are my bridge
you are responsible for filming not even
the subject but just you you alone are
responsible for all that we see here all
that we enjoy on a daily basis all you i
love that about you man you are uh
absolute delight you smell like corn
puffs
i love a good corn puff i do too i love
to dip you in almond milk because i'm
allergic to dairy and then eat you up
dude deep fry you with a twinkie enjoy
all that creamy michael goodness yeah
man
you taste so good
i'm not talking about like you know
perverted stuff youtube since you guys
are so sensitive about it
i'm talking about devouring him
you know eating him yeah like army
actual eating not
not not something gross i'm not a yeah
not a perv yeah i'm talking about
chewing him yeah
gnawing nibbling at his epidermis a
light chomp or two or four or seven or
as many as it takes really don't be
sensitive the titsy roll of our channel
all right mikhail can't wait to eat you
buddy
i don't
really know how many licks
gets the center of the kale
[Music]